janosch bevor du angefangen hast
professionell interviews mit easy german
zu machen was war denn der beschissenen
job den du je hattest
also ich hab schon ziemlich viele
beschissene jobs die man im leben
gewirkt aber der schlimmste war
tatsächlich ware in die regale bei rewe
anzunehmen das war schlimm und wie lange
hast du das ausgehalten ich glaube zwei
oder drei wochen und dann wurde hat man
mich man hat mich rausgeschmissen weil
ich immer wieder gefehlt habe und
das haben sie nicht toleriert
gottseidank sonst wärst du jetzt nicht
hier bei 7 wir fragen heute die menschen
in berlin was ist die beschissene job
den du je hattest los geht's los geht's
[Musik]
heute ist die frage was war der härteste
langweiligste beschissen sste job den
sie irgendwann in ihrem leben haben
machen müssen im büro
frauenverband behörde das war ja die
zeit läuft nicht da musste man schon
sein kopf abgeben wenn man rein kam
sagen dir danken oder hatte ich
eigentlich nicht sagen sorry
das ist ein langweiligster job das war
der schlimmste job den sie hier gemacht
haben
ich habe nur tolle jobs gemacht ich habe
keine schlimmen jobs gemacht der
schuhshop
und was soll ich es vielleicht eine
studie hat er ja ich hatte immer das
riesengroße glück ich muss immer nur
zeugs machen wo ich lust drauf hatte
mein schlimmstes hier hatte ich hatte
nur einen job ist ja der war eigentlich
gut ich bin seit sieben jahren dort
also keine schlimme erfahrungen hast du
dann kann ich dir nur gratulieren danke
das hält mir wichtig sein
als student weihnachtsdekoration in dem
kaufhaus ahrens in marburg und
was war das schlimm daran es hört sich
gut an es war draußen es war kalt und
ich bin handwerklich unbegabt also mein
beschützer oder härtester job war
tatsächlich im büro als er weiß nicht
körperlich anstrengend aber ich musste
den ganzen tag profile raussuchen von
von plattformen wie xing und linkedin
und musste jeden von den einzelnen die
nachricht schreiben und das habe ich
eine ganze woche lang gemacht ich jeden
tag acht stunden und zwar so stupide und
immer dasselbe und total monotonen da
bin ich echt
sich ein teenager
habe ich in einen ice laden gearbeitet
und das war lecker lecker aber
hat irgendwie komischerweise hat es
nicht so viel spaß gemacht
ich habe zu schulzeiten als ich noch zur
schule gegangen bin bei burger king
gearbeitet
und eigentlich war das kein schlimmer
job weil es war ein lustiges team ein
anstrengender chef aber wir waren ein
gutes team aber ich erinnere mich hat
wirklich ein kleines trauma an einem tag
musste ich eine mülltonne die draußen
stand von kakerlaken befreien und das
war glaube ich die schlimmste aufgabe
und die ekligste aufgabe die ich jemals
beruflich machen musste bei mir war es
auch ein bürojob da musste ich mieten
eintrag für eine hausverwaltung von
studentenwohnungen und musste ich glaube
drei monate lang eigentlich fast jeden
tag immer die gleichen zahlen wieder im
tabellen- eintragen und namen und daten
ja das war auch so ein bisschen sinnlos
ich habe nicht gesehen dass wir noch
schnell langweilig das werden die ersten
jobs de an die roboter übergehen na
hoffentlich
die roboter gerne übernehmen ja gefehlt
was ein als ferienjob als schülerin bei
einem fleisch laden als vegetarierin
okay das ist wirklich schlimm oder
ja aber der anderen seite weil sie ja
egal na ja ich mache was ich jetzt aber
ich musste immer durch den laden durch
wo die wiener gemacht wurden also ich
hab da in der küche gearbeitet deswegen
ja woraus bestehen sind wien aus allen
resten ich glaube ja da wird alles
zusammen gekehrt
pflastersteine liegen
und ich dachte immer das ist ein schöner
job das ist auch ein schöner job wenn
man ganz viel spaß dran hat aber es ist
unglaublich anstrengend ist und schlecht
bezahlt
überhaupt keinen also ich habe meinen
beruf geliebt ich war 45 jahre trompeter
im orchester und hat ja auch nie was
anderes im sinn zwar sind einige warte
ich muss ich muss ganz kurz nachdenken
[Gelächter]
das war nicht hart ich habe mal
trägt er seit studenten ein solitär
fachhandel kleine dichtungsringe
eingepackt und wasserhähne und so ein
zeug das war absolut langweilig und
überflüssig und blöd ich habe schon
recht viele stopps gemacht der
beschissen sste
nach im blumenladen zu arbeiten was war
die blumen sind doch so schön was war da
ja ich habe studentin
und da ich keine floristin waren waren
die kunden sehr unfreundliche weil die
wollten immer bedient werden von einer
floristin ja ja ja aber es war sehr
schlecht bezahlt auch also es gab den
sinnlosen und dem beschissenes in den
beschissenen wahlen mit so einer
eisdiele während ich mein fachabitur
gemacht hat und der schärfe ein
absoluter choleriker hat nur
umgeschrieben zwar mein erster
arbeitstag und es war super chefs hat
richtig richtig schlecht bezahlt und
das sinnloseste war für mich tatsächlich
bei h&m sachen zusammenlegen ich habe
einfach ich würde es nicht schlecht
machen den job für andere ist es
vielleicht gut aber ich habe nur sachen
zusammengelegt und dann kam wieder leute
haben den ganzen stapel mit sachen
wieder durch gerissen und du stehst und
muss halt den mund halten das kann jeder
affe machen und das hat ich fand das
ganze register ohne kopf ohne geist und
kapseln bisher ausgehalten
gute frage
ich glaube das wird der job im
biergarten gewesen sein wo ich bei sehr
heißen sommertemperaturen
kisten mit schmutzigen wäsche in die
küche in die waschküche tragen muss den
ganzen tag sehr schwere kisten und die
dann auch spielen und sich noch die alle
seiten anhören wie kellnern grünen genau
die besoffenen touris an anja da bin ich
nicht
okay danke dafür
[Gelächter]
14 jahre war habe ich den job gemacht
einer stanze der musik nichts weiter
machen immer als als ein stück metall da
rein legen in so einer form und
einlegen reilingen wisst ihr werk einen
beschissenen job hat janosch und ich wir
haben nämlich genau genommen einen
traumberuf wir gehen auf die straße
machen interviews und wir kreieren
nützliche deutsch lernen materialien für
euch und das ganze machen wir auch dank
euch denn tatsächlich finanzieren wir
unser projekt vor allem durch
mitgliedschaften wie funktioniert das
ihr werdet ein mitglied bei easyjet für
einen monat für drei monate oder für ein
jahr so lange ihr wollt in dieser zeit
unterstützt wir unsere produktion und
gleichzeitig bekommt ihr dafür übungen
transkripte ihr chatteten und uns und
habe viele tolle andere extras hier oben
findet ihr den link um ein mitglied zu
werden und wir würden uns wahnsinnig
freuen wenn ihr uns damit unterstützt
[Musik]
und was haben sie aus dieser erfahrung
gelernt
dass es geht immer weiter also das
bleibt nicht beim blumenladen und was
war das für euch finde lebenserfahrung
was habt ihr davon gelernt
das leben viel zu schade ist um sich mit
sowas so die zeit zu vergeuden also bei
mir war das ein praktikum ich habe dann
auch gesagt ich dass ich das nicht mehr
kann als ich habe dann auch früher
aufgehört und
mir dann auch gedacht dass es viel
wichtiger ist etwas das man was macht
was einem spaß macht weil dafür geht
auch die zeit nicht und das ist so
mühsam
das ist also das bei mir aber es war
trotzdem macht der erste job und das
erste geld das erste eigene deswegen in
dem fall war es schon eine gute
erfahrung aber auf jeden fall auch dass
man was sinnvolles machen könnte mit der
zeit ich habe gelernt dass ein stabiler
job mich krank macht ich habe schlecht
geschlafen hatte ich schlechte laune ja
aber
begrifflich mit 14 jahren mit in diesen
fällen job dass ich so was nie im leben
machen möchte mir ich muss so was
ähnliches also nie etwas struppi ist
immer etwas interessant ist ja ich fand
das jetzt nicht schlimm von der arbeit
her also ich habe keine angst vor arbeit
ich finde arbeit ist ehrenwert egal was
es ist und von daher war es nicht
schlimm es hat mich nur noch mal
bekräftigt vegetarierin zu bleiben das
auf jeden fall aber dann besteht schon
eine ganze weile begeht er ich bin schon
seit meinem 15 lebensjahr vegetarierin
ja schon ziemlich lange und was hast du
von diesem schlechten erfahrungen
gelernt das ist so was nie wieder will
was ist dieses letztendlich geworden was
sie verwenden erwitter im fitness
bereich
das mag es gerne und was war das für sie
als eine lebenserfahrung was haben sie
daraus gelernt
dass ich das natürlich meine richtung
ist sondern dass ich eher arbeiten
verfolgen sollte die man wo ich mein
eigenes talent einsetzen kann würde ich
mit dem kopf arbeiten kann und nicht mit
diesen händen das ist richtig und was
arbeiten sie es denn ich bin journalist
und als journalist
genießen sie den job oder oder kräfte
ist manchmal überhaupt nicht überhaupt
nicht das ist auch mit all den schlimmen
nachrichten aus der ganzen welt na ja
ich bin jetzt kein politischer
journalist ja aber das schreiben macht
spaß ja auf jeden lesen macht spaß auf
jeden fall und man wird bezahlt ok und
was sind sie dann geworden fünf
geschäftsführer das heißt ich mache
nichts sondern sich sitzen lassen ich
bin professor für umweltökonomie wie
heute ich hab ja ich habe das große
vergnügen genau junge leute
in sachen umweltschutz bis hin zu
unterrichten und hoffe dass dieser
selber auf die idee kommen dazu
beizutragen die welt ein bisschen besser
zu machen ich bin selbstständig in der
baubranche und
in der baubranche in berlin läuft
abenteuerlich oder läuft abenteuer ist
ja es geht bergauf schon seit seit
langem schon seit jahren arbeit heutigen
menschen mit behinderungen für die
lebenshilfe und nach dort
reisebegleitung auch ende des
präsidenten der akademie der lebenshilfe
das ist wunderschöne tiefe
also die tolle menschen die ich habe mal
wieder treffe und interessante
herausforderungen aber es ist so
bereichernd für mich auch vor allen
dingen ja in kindergärten und es ist
schön also sieben arbeiten als
kindergärtnerin und was ist das schönste
und was ist das schlimmste an den beruf
das schlimmste
nicht lustig
und das schönste ja also was sie für
eine lustige ideen haben also nicht
sogar abend das cool
jetzt wollen wir von euch wissen was es
denn der beschissenen job den ihr je
gemacht habt schreibt uns mal eure
geschichten auf deutsch dass es auch
eine gute übung für euch und wenn ihr
möchte dass wir nie wieder einen
beschissenen job machen müssen sondern
mit unseren traum job weitermachen
dürfen nämlich videos für euch zu
produzieren jede woche dann könnt ihr
ein mitglied werden von easy german
damit unterstützt hier unsere arbeit und
ihr stellt sicher dass wir jede woche
für euch weiter produzieren und ihr
macht uns wahnsinnig glücklich den link
zu unserer mitgliedschaft seite posten
wir unten und wir sehen uns nächste
woche wieder janisch oder ja und das
freut uns danke leute bis bald